We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a question I'm increasingly
getting about the possibility of mandatory
covid vaccinations.
Take a listen.
Hi, David, this is Talia from North Carolina.
My question is, with the vaccine getting rolled
out and Biden making it one of his priorities,
what do you think will happen with mandatory
vaccines for kids in schools?
Because I know that there's many vaccines
that the government has made mandatory for
people to go to school.
So do you think Biden will have to decide
on that?
So, no, Joe Biden is not going to have to
decide on that decisions about vaccine requirements
for attending public school are typically
made at the state level.
They may even be made at a more local level,
but typically those are state level decisions.
I think we need to be really careful with
our terminology here.
A mandatory vaccine is a vaccine that you
are required to have.
Rather than simply one that you can choose
to have if you want to participate in a certain
activity or avail yourself of a certain business
service or educational institution.
So it's really important that we be clear
with the language.
The coronavirus vaccine is not going to be
mandatory in the sense that no government,
state, local, federal, is going to force anyone
who doesn't want a vaccine to get one.
What we are going to see, and we're already
hearing from it, is that everything from airlines
to yes, maybe schools will say if you or your
kid want to travel with us, come to a concert,
Live Nation, Ticketmaster, or talking about
this, maybe attend our school, which is your
choice to do or not to do.
You would be required to be vaccinated.
Now, you don't have to be vaccinated.
You just might not be able to fly JetBlue.
Maybe Delta will allow you.
I think Delta already said they're going to
require vaccinations.
This is hypothetical at a private school.
Could also say at this school you have to
have a coronavirus vaccine to attend.
Some private schools have laxer rules on vaccination
than public schools.
Some don't.
So it's really important that we not fall
into this idea of a vaccine made mandatory
by a government.
Public schools are run by states and municipalities.
They're not going to force a vaccine on anyone.
But they may say if you choose to send your
kid to the school, they must have a vaccine,
as is already the case with a number of different
vaccines in different states and municipalities.
So let's take control of what this actually
is, which are requirements for participation
as as they exist in many different areas across
many different industries.
And I do expect that many businesses, because
of the risk to their business of coronavirus
outbreaks, will have a variety of different
guidelines that say if you want to fly with
us or travel on our train or whatever employers
might say, we require employees to be vaccinated
for this or that.
You don't have to work here.
Working here is optional.
You can go to a different employer if you
want.
But to work here, you need this vaccine or
that vaccine fully expect that that is going
to happen.
It'll be up to people to decide whether they
want to avail themselves of a certain school
or of a certain airline or whatever, enough
that they will choose to go and get that vaccine.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about a federal judge temporarily
blocking Joe Biden's paws on deportation.
We will talk about how in 20, 20 airports,
people were caught with guns twice as much
in twenty twenty than in twenty nineteen at
American airports.
And we will talk about the possibility of
mandatory covid tests for domestic air travel.
I actually think this is long overdue, and
I will explain why on today's bonus show,
get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at Join Pakman Dotcom.